how the economic machine
works in 30 minutes
the economy works like a
simple machine but many people
don't understand it or have
different opinions that has led to
unnecessary economic hardship
i feel a strong responsibility
to share a simple but practical economic guide
although unconventional  he
helped me anticipate and avoid the world financial crisis
and he has served me for over 30 years
let's start
although the economy seems complex it
works in a simple
mechanical way
there are some simple parts and many
simple transactions that will repeat itself over
and over again
these transactions  perceive
started by humans and they
create three has driving forces for the
economy number one
productivity growth number two the
short-term debt cycle and number
three the long-term debt cycle
let's look at each other  these three forces and
how they are superimposed a good
guide to tracking
economic conditions and
understanding what is happening
let's start with the simplest part of the
economy transactions an
economy is simply the sum of
its transactions and a transaction
is something very simple you make
constant transactions every time you
shop this is a transaction every
transaction has a buyer who buys goods for
money or credit from the seller
services or
investments credits are like cash expenditures so
by adding them up with the cash
expenditures you get the
total expenditure
these total expenditures drive the
economy  dividing expenses
by quantity sold gives
price that's all that's a
transaction it's the building block of the
economic machine all
business cycles and forces are usually driven by
transactions so if we can
understand transactions  let's understand the
whole economy
a market is made up of all the buyers and all the
sellers who transact on the same things
for example
there is a wheat a machine in
the stock markets for the pss any things
an economy is made up of all of
these transactions in all of its
markets
if you look at the  total consumption added up
and total sales volume in all
markets you have everything you need to
know to understand the economy
as simple as that people companies
banks governments all deal
with transaction as just described
through the exchange of money and credit
for goods services and
investments of
the  largest buyers and sellers is the
state which consists of two important
parts a government which taxes and
issues money and a central
bank which differs from other buyers and
sellers in that it controls the supply of money and credit in the economy it
does so by influencing our goal
set and by printing money so
as we will see the
central bank plays a major role in
the flow of credit pay special attention to
credit credit is the most important part of
the economy and probably the
least understood it is the
most important part because we make up the
majority and  of the most volatile
buyers and sellers in the market
transacting, so do
lenders and borrowers usually lenders want to
grow their money and
borrowers want to buy something they don't
have the money for like a house or
a car or they want to
fund the start up of a new business they can borrow from
Both lenders and
borrowers make wishes
for the climate promise a
repayment of their debt called the
loan amount plus an additional amount
the interest rates when the target rates
are high less money is borrowed because it is
expensive when interest rates
are low borrowing increases because
it is cheaper  st when borrowers
promise to repay and
lenders believe them a loan is created two people can always
conjure credit out of thin air
sounds simple but credit is
complicated because it has different
names once a loan
is made it turns into a debt
debt is a win for the
lender and a liability for
the borrower later when a
borrower repays his loan with interest
assets
innocence disappear and the transaction is
complete
why so is credit so important
because through credit the borrower
can increase spending
and think back spending drives
the economy
because  just one person's
output is another's income every dollar spent is someone else's earnings
and every
dollar earned is someone
else's output so if you spend more someone
else earns more
if nobody's income is
city  the lender he elected
to borrow money
because now he is more creditworthy a
creditworthy borrower has
two things repays and collateral
with more income relative to the
debt he can repay
them he cannot he has valuable assets
that serve as salable collateral
the satisfied  lenders give him
the money increased income
thus allowing more borrowing almost leads to
overspending and as it is an
expense to the other merit for
this leads to increased borrowing and so
on they self-reinforcing
patterns for economic growth and
explains why we must have cycles in
transactions  one
gives to receive
in the long run the amount received is
determined by how much one produces over
time we learn that
accumulated knowledge increases living standards productivity growth
those who are creative and
work hard increase their productivity and
their  standard of living quicker than those
who are foul satisfied but in the
short term that's not entirely true
long term productivity
is what matters most but in the short term it is
credit because productivity growth is
not very sophisticated it is not a big
driver of economic activity oscillations
debt is what allows us
to consume more than we do  produce and
force us to repay less
than we produce debt
vibrations occur in two major
cycles one spanning five
to eight years the other 75 to
100 years
while most
feel the vibrations they
don't usually perceive them as cycles
you experience them up close day after
day week after week in this chapter
we take a step back and
look at the big forces and how
their interrelationship shapes our
experience as said,
vibrations around the line are not created
by the number of innovations or  r
hard work
it exists mainly as a result of the
existing supply of credit let
's briefly imagine an economy without credit
in this economy i can
only increase my spending if i
increase my income which
requires more productivity and more work from me
increased productivity is the only
way  to growth since my expenses are someone else's
merit the
economy grows every time I or
others are more productive if we
follow the transactions and
carry this on there is an increase in
the productivity growth line but
as we lazily buy we have
cycles
that lies  not to laws or
regulations but to
human nature and how politics
works borrowing is concerned
simply as a way to
drive spending to buy something you don't have money for you
have to spend more than you
earn so basically you have to
make money from your own future  borrow
thereby generate  you a time in the
future when you can't
spend as much as you earn
on your debts on issues
this very quickly resembles a cycle you create a cycle
so every
time you borrow money
this is true for individuals as well as
for the economy
That's why it's so important to understand credit because it sets in motion
a future
mechanically predictable series of
events.
That's how credit differs from money. Money
is
needed to complete transactions. When you
pay cash to a bartender, the
transaction is instantaneous
However, if you don't pay for a beer with credit
, it's as if you were
writing to
them. You promise to pay in the future. You
and the bartender create a
wealth of innocence.
You have created credit out of nothing
the debt disappears and
the transaction is completed  n
in reality this is what most
applicable credit actually is the
total credit in the
us is about $50 million
while the total money is only about $3
million remember in an
economy without credit increased
production is the only way to spend
increase
but in an economy with credit one
can also increase spending by
borrowing
result an economy with credit can
spend more and incomes can
rise faster than
productivity in the short run
but not in the
long run don't get me wrong credit is not necessarily
a bad thing that only cycles
causes it is bad if it is
financed through consumption because it cannot be repaid
it is good if it allocates funds
efficiently and
produces income with which you can repay debts
if, for example,
you buy a larger television set on credit
it can work around for you
owe to
but if you buy a tractor on credit
and it helps you to get more
crops and make more money you can
pay off your debts and
improve your standard of living
in an economy on credit
we can follow the transactions and see
how credit creates growth let me give you
an example  let's say you
make $100,000 a year
with no debt your credit rating
allows you to borrow $10,000
say with a credit card now you can
spend $110,000 even though you
only make $100,000 because your spending is
someone else's income someone makes $110,000
the debt free person with the  $
110,000 can be 11,000 small and can
spend 121,000 dollars even though she only
earned 110,000 her expenses are
someone else's income and by
following the transactions
we begin to see how this
process works in animal's self-affirming pattern keep in mind
though that
borrowing e.g  yklen creates and when the
cycle goes up it has to come down at some point
this brings us to the short term
debt cycle as economic activity picks up
we see
expansion
the first phase of the short term
debt cycle spending continues
to rise and prices are dragging this is
happening because the elevated  spending
is fueled by credit that can be instantly created from scratch
when spending and income
grows faster than
production of goods prices rise
when prices rise we call it
inflation the central bank does not want
high inflation as this
creates problems rising prices raise interest rates
at  higher interest rates fewer
people can borrow money and the cost of
existing debt
increases think of it as if the
monthly payment on your credit card goes up as
less money is borrowed and you hear
debt
repayments less money is left over and spending is down  people like
each other and since someone's expenses are someone
else's income incomes go down
and so on and so forth
if you spend less
prices go down win that deflation the
economy slows down and we
have a recession when the recession
gets too bad and inflation  it is no
longer a problem if the central bank
lowers interest rates so that the economy
can recover again
if interest rates are low the repayment
amounts fall borrowing and consumption pick up
again
and we are experiencing expansion again
as you can see the
economy works like a machine
in the short-term debt
cycle  Consumption only reined in by the willingness
of
lenders to take and give credit When
credit is easy
the economy expands If not there is a
recession Note that this
cycle is primarily
controlled by
the central bank The course to victory Debt cycle
lasts in  usually five to ah  t years
and repeats itself over and over for decades
but note that the end and
beginning of each cycle produces more growth
and debt than its
predecessor why because people
drive
it they have a propensity to borrow and
spend more and city to
pay
down their debts it  is human therefore in
the long run debt goes up faster than income this creates the long term debt
cycle even though people keep going into debt lenders are
granting more and more
permissive credit why because everyone
thinks everything is going great
people only focus on
recent feelings and what is up  long gone
incomes are up and assets are up league stock market
we're booming
it's worth buying goods services and
equipment with borrowed money
cuz that takes over
when we it's a bubble even though
debts are up so incomes are
almost the same
so let's call the ratio of
debt to income the
debt burden as long as income continues to
rise the debt
burden remains manageable people are taking
huge
bucks to buy the heaping investments making them even more expensive
people feel rich so that
Even with the accumulation of high
debts, rising incomes and
assets help the
debtors to remain creditworthy for a long time,
but of course this cannot always
go on like this
, it does not continue to do so over the years,
the debt burden slowly fills up and the
repayment amounts increase
at some point, the repayment
participants grow faster than  the income
and force people
to cut their expenses and since the expenses of one
person are the income of the other, the income goes down, which leads to lower creditworthiness and fewer loans, the repayments increase,
walter expenses are further throttled  t
and the cycle reverses
this is the long term debt
peak the debt burden has
just gotten too big
for the us europe and most of the
rest of the world this happened in 2008 it
happened for the same reason it happened in
1989 in japan and in 1929 in  the
usa is
now starting the economy and construction
debt reduction means less spending
income is falling credit is disappearing investment prices are
falling baten come under
pressure the stock market collapses
social tensions arise and the
whole system begins to unravel itself conversely
with falling incomes and rising principal payments borrowers
come
under pressure  when they are no longer
creditworthy, the loan disappears and
the borrowers do not have enough money
to make their repayments
to fill the hole, they are forced
to sell
their investments the onslaught of asset sellers has overwhelmed
the market at the same time as
spending decreases at this point the
shares of the  immobilien ag in baden and
the banks washed the difficulties
with investments are sinking the value of the collateral of the debt will
be that makes
them still unworthy of credit people
feel destitute
rapid credit dwindling occurs less consumption
less income less prosperity
less credit less borrowing
and so on  it's a vicious circle
it seems similar to a recession but
the difference is that
interest rates can be lowered offer a lifeline
in a recession lowering interest
rates stimulates borrowing to reduce
debt
interest rates do not benefit interest
rates are already low at almost
zero percent
so the stimulus ended interest rates in
the us went down to 0% during
the deleveraging of the 1930's and
again in 2008 the difference between
a recession and deleveraging
is that in deleveraging the
debtor is simply overleveraging
and through a
rate cut  g cannot be relieved
the lenders realize that the debts
have become too high to ever pay off in full
the debtors are no longer able to
pay back and their securities
have lost their value
they feel handicapped by the
debt and no longer want to deal with
lenders and  take stops
interest imagine the
economy as uncreditworthy
similar to a person so
what do you do when reducing debt
the problem is that the debt load is too
high and needs to
be reduced this can happen in many ways
firstly people under
government companies reduce their spending
secondly the  debt is reduced through
default and restructuring
third, wealth is redistributed from the
sectors to the poor, and
finally, fourth, the central bank
prints new money. these four
tactics have been used in every
debt reduction process in modern
history,
usually spending first
cut as event people
companies and banks and even the
state cut back and cut spending to
pay off their debt
this is often referred to as austerity when borrowers stop
borrowing and start paying off old
debt one would
expect the debt burden to decrease
but  the opposite is
happening because spending is curbed and one person's expenses are another's income which leads to declining incomes they are falling faster than the repayments the debt burden is
increasing so we have seen that
this spending is for deflationary and
painful companies
forced to cut costs fits
less work and higher
unemployment means this leads to the
next step debt needs to be
reduced
many borrowers are unable to
repay their loans and borrowers
' debts are the
assets of lenders when
borrowers of the ba  nk not
making repayments bank man that the
bank could
default there is a run on the banks the
banks are under pressure and people
companies and banks are
defaulting this serious
economic downturn is a
depression
in a depression people
mainly discover that you assume that
assets does not exist we go
back to the bar
if you order and
leave a note do you promise
to pay the bartender
we promise will be the
bartender's assets if you
don't keep your promise if you don't pay and
basically cheat your bill
then his is supposed to be  assets
worthless basically there are not
many lenders reluctant to see their assets
disappear and are willing to
restructure debt restructuring means
lower repayments over longer
periods or at lower interest rates than
originally agreed how does a
breach of contract of some kind lead to debt reduction  au the
creditor would rather have the bird in the
hand than the pigeon on the roof
although the debt is swinging,
deleveraging leads to faster income
and asset erosion and the
debt burden continues to worsen
like spending cuts, deleveraging is also
painful and
inflationary
all of which affect the government  from
less income less work
means less tax revenue
at the same time the expenses increase due to
increasing unemployment many
unemployed people have hardly any savings and
need state
support there are also the state
support packages that also increase spending
to help the economy
the state budget deficit
explodes when debt is reduced
because spending is higher  as the
tax revenue
that's what happens when the news
reports
about the budget deficit in order to finance the deficit
either the taxes or the
debt have to be increased
where, however, should be reduced  n revenue
and high unemployment the money
comes
from the rich as the state needs more money
and the wealth is in the
hands of a small percentage of the
population the state increases taxes on
the rich which facilitates the
redistribution of wealth in the
economy
from the rich to  the poor
the suffering poor are starting
to get angry with the rich the rich
falling asset values ​​due to the weak economy higher taxes are
starting to get angry at the poor
prolonged depression can lead to social
unrest tensions are
rising not only in the country
they can also spread across borders in
particular  spread between creditor and
debtor countries
this can lead to political
changes which can sometimes be extreme
in the 1930s
up to the seizure of power the glass of wine to
war in europe to the economic crisis in
the
usa the pressure to end the economic crisis is
increasing
remember the assumed  ne people's
wealth was
really credit so when credit goes away
people don't have enough
money people need desperate will
remember who can print the money
the central
bank after cutting interest rates to almost
zero they are forced to print money
differently than  with spending
cuts debt reduction distribution of wealth money printing is inflationary and the
economy inevitably encourages printing
the central bank new money out of
thin air and used to buy
financial assets and government bonds
this is what happened in the us at the time of the economic
crisis and again in 2008
when the us central bank took over the federal
reserve  two trillion dollars
pressed other central banks worldwide
this could also pressed a lot of
money
the purchase of financial assets with the money
enables the price to
rise which makes people like the
creditworthy but it only helps
those who own financial assets because
the central bank can  hit but
only buy financial
assets the government on the other hand can buy goods
and services and distribute the money
among the population but it
cannot print money in order to stimulate the
economy both have to
cooperate in which the central
bank buys government bonds sorry the state
money and allows as a  deficit and
increased spending on goods and
services through subsidy programs
and
jobless benefits per capita income is rising
but so is government debt
however it is helping to bring down the economy's overall debt burden
this
is a very risky time
policy makers need to weigh four ways to bring down the debt burden
deflationary steps need to be taken
Balancing the inflationary steps
to maintain stability
when balanced correctly can lead
to beautiful debt reduction
see debt reduction can be hideous
or beautiful how can debt ab
also be beautiful
despite debt reduction  a difficult
situation is its best
handling and beauty better than the
debt burden may depend on imbalanced
processes of debt phases
with good debt reduction debt goes down
relative to income
real economic growth is positive
and inflation is not a problem
this is achieved with the right
balance the right one  compensation
requires some mix of
spending cuts debt reduction and
wealth transfer and printing
money to maintain economic
and social stability
looking forward to money watching
inflation increases no not if it
makes up for the credit shortage you know spending
matters  spent dollars in cash has the
same effect on the price as the
issue via credit payment in which the
central bank prints money, it can make up for the
lack of credit with more money in order to
bring about a restructuring, the
central bank not only has to make the
purchase  promote growth but also increase
the growth rate of income via the
interest rate of debt accumulation
what do I mean by that in principle
income must grow faster than
debt an example let's take a
country that is pursuing debt reduction
then a debt-to
-income ratio of 100 percent
that means the  the amount of his debt is
equal to the annual income of the
whole country
now imagine the interest rate on
that debt let's say it's
2 percent
if the debt through the interest by 26
and income by only about
1 percent you're never going to reduce the debt burden
you have to enough  printing money to bring the
income rate above the interest rate
however, printing money can be easily
abused because it is easy
and it is preferred over the alternatives
the point is not to print too much money
and not
to cause undesirably high inflation like in
germany during the deleveraging period
the 20s  Earning when policy makers strike
the right
balance deleveraging is
not that dramatic growth is
slow but debt burdens are falling it
's nicer deleveraging as
incomes rise borrowers appear
more creditworthy and
when they appear creditworthy lenders
start offering credit again to
wind down the debt burden
to go down
people can borrow and
spend more again
the economy starts to grow again
leading to the reflation phase of the
long-term debt cycle
although a poorly managed
debt reduction process
can be horrific
if managed properly it will eventually fix the problem
it takes about a decade or more
to break through  to reduce the burden of debt and
to normalize the economy,
hence the term lost decade
to conclude, of course, that the
economy is a little more complicated
than this guideline suggests,
but in the short term  igen debt cycle
over the long-term and then both
over the productivity growth line
there is a relatively good guide
to see where we have been,
where we are now and where we are
likely to be
going  don't let debt grow
faster than income
or one day the debt
will crush you
second don't let income grow
faster than productivity
otherwise one day you will be
unable to compete and third do whatever you
can to increase your productivity
because in the long run it is  what
matters this is simple advice
for you and policy makers
you may be surprised but
most people including
policy
makers are not paying enough attention this guide
has served me well and i hope it
helps you too thanks